what's up guys we're talking about the
samsung galaxy z fold for as much
as i really like this phone
i can't recommend it as a daily driver
here are my reasons why first and
foremost design
now this is pretty much the same design
as we've seen from the original fold
four iterations ago and i liked that
phone back in the day that was a game
changer but samsung really hasn't
changed the design that much i mean yes
you could say the edges are a little bit
more refined better quality materials
the hinge feels a little bit better but
it feels still like two phones slab
together on an angle it looks very
feels like they need to update it a bit
and it makes it very bulky and very not
easy to carry around which brings me to
the number two point ergonomics this is
a very thick foam okay and it's also
kind of this candy bar narrow shape now
if you're using this full screen on the
front of it you want to do pretty much
all your phone tasks like that the
keyboard is very narrow you're going to
do a lot of misti strokes on that but
also the same time you want to open it
up but then you're also worried about
damaging that front display if you're a
content creator you want to get creative
with your shots you want to take this
out and you want to do some things with
it it's a little bit
still a little bit neither here nor
there i don't feel it's as refined as it
could be as of yet it'd have been nice
if the phone was actually a little bit
wider case in point
like
the huawei mate xs2 now this when i open
it up feels like a smartphone the size
of the front of it feels a like a normal
smartphone to me which is enjoyable it's
more convenient it's easier for me to
use and navigate with
this feels a little bit too narrow also
because of the weight and because it's
so sleek and so narrow you put this in
pants that aren't like tight jeans like
what i got here right here you sit down
at a table chances are it's going to
fall out if you want to cycle you want
to run you want to exercise because of
the ergonomics of this thing because of
the weight you may have a drop phone
and that's a very expensive phone to
drop next let's talk about protection
the original fold had a nice case inside
of at least a cover to at least protect
a little bit of the phone
now with the fold four you get nothing
you get a box and a cable
and that's it
samsung now wants you to buy the
accessories now they could say oh it's
about being eco-friendly and spending
less on packaging and i'll call that bs
and i'll tell you why because you still
gotta buy it guess where that case comes
into another package
so this whole eco thing is just a way
for them to make money and you're
spending twenty six hundred dollars
singapore dollars mind you for the 512
version of this phone that's a lot of
money
for a phone and they don't even give you
covers to protect this yes you can say
that this invictus glass is durable or
they can say it's more durable but i'll
tell you what and i haven't tried it you
drop this phone once you've got to worry
about that foldable display inside of it
you gotta worry about the glass on the
outside of it and i would not want to
get this thing replaced because it's
gonna cost a pretty bomb
and last but not least the overall
usability of the phone it's cool with
samsung's done with the software you can
continue from what you're doing on the
inside to the outside of it
but i still feel
that they haven't mastered the ability
to use a foldable phone in a way
that feels just like you're using your
normal phone i feel like they've done
this better with the z flip 4 than when
they're done with the fold 4. now these
are just my personal opinions you may
disagree with me on this
but i feel like this shape and this
design
i've never gotten comfortable with it
for longer periods of time and i was
hoping that samsung would have changed
the shape a little bit make it a little
bit more user-friendly over time make it
a little bit thinner make it just more
easier to use
and they do a bit of it with software
but at the same time
i still don't feel comfortable with it
now let's talk about some positives real
quick because this is not all about
negativity okay the dock the dock on the
bottom of this is absolutely awesome and
this was a feature that they should have
had a long time ago it really does make
navigating the phone a lot easier
especially when you have it opened up
and it gives it more of that sort of
that pc more of that laptop or you know
tablet feel versus what it was before
was just kind of like a a wider screen
phone um outside of that power the
performance it's great the cameras are
really good not as good as the galaxy
line uh the main line that we tested
earlier this year but you know what to
the average person they're not going to
notice a difference if you want to do
video and want to do photography the
cameras out of this are great but to me
it goes back to that feel that
ergonomics and just
i just don't feel secure with this phone
to recommend it as a daily driver but if
you have the extra coin and you want to
make this as your secondary phone go for
it but if you want one foldable phone to
get as a daily driver i would recommend
the z-flip four to me i love what they
done with that design it makes a lot of
sense clam shell small fit in your
pockets you're on the go and it just
works awesomely anyway those are my
thoughts on the galaxy fold four let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below do you agree with me do
you disagree with me anyway we've got
many more phone reviews coming up click
on these right here